I guess who just turned up at my place
it is grant Thompson the king of random
what's up guys grant is actually gonna
show me a little survival tip let's say
you're stuck out in the woods and you
need to make a fire but you don't have
st. matches or a lighter we're gonna try
to use a ziploc bag to start a fire I
guess when you're building a fire the
first thing you're gonna need is some
tinder so we're gonna have to go
scavenge around for some options this
stuff works pretty well now this is
pretty dry yeah we definitely want
something that's off the ground if
possible because we need it as dry as
possible the first step was to grind up
the tinder into a fine powder I'm just
following Grant's instructions here I'm
not really sure if this is gonna work
see that right there hmm
that's the stuff we're going for it's
super fine we're gonna take our base
plate we're gonna pinch a nice little
pile in there okay so this point we're
pretty much ready to start the ignition
process so whatever I need for that
we're gonna need a ziplock bag a little
bit of water now this is just a regular
ziplock sandwich baggie we're gonna pour
that Intel it's about halfway full you
let me know when grab water from a creek
or stream or wherever you like now
here's the trick we want to develop this
into some kind of a liquid sphere we're
gonna be making a liquid magnifying
glass I do that by turning my ziplock
bag you know 45 degrees so it creates
this diamond shape and then we're just
gonna gather these two corners together
we're gonna lose a little bit of water
as we do okay we're gonna pinch that off
and the next goal is to twist it trap
all that water inside you see as I twist
it it creates pressure that exerts
almost an equal pressure on all sides
and now while it's not a perfect sphere
it will eventually start to bubble out
into a nice liquid sphere where we need
it we've essentially just made a
makeshift magnifying glass and you start
the fire the same way you would with a
magnifying glass now once you roll the
ball around you can see where it looks
the best we're looking for as close to a
sphere as possible which is right there
now if I back it out wow you can see
there and start smoking immediately
that's incredible the focal length of a
lens is the place where all of the light
converges so that's really what we're
trying to establish here right is
position the tinder pile at the focal
point of this spherical by convex lens
essentially now you can see this has
been smoking for a little while mm-hmm
we've developed a little bit of an ember
base it's burned a little bit yeah yeah
and so now I'm gonna sprinkle a little
bit more fuel on top there and that will
cause the heat to rise and burn that
from the bottom and I'm going to
again from the top nice that's
interesting how you're like kind of
bringing it down so that the surface of
that is not actually where the most
concentrated rays are you're
concentrating even deeper down into the
pile that's right because we don't want
the heat to dissipate too much and if
we're at an extreme focal point like
this yes the heats gonna bleed off so if
we can warm the surrounding area it
actually helps speed the process right
we're just gonna repeat that process
until it will stay smoking on its own
we've only been at this for a minute or
two and the amount of smoke we're seeing
there is it's pretty significant
a little bit of sprinkle a little bit of
sunlight rinse and repeat really
elevating the temperature mm-hmm at this
point our pile smoking pretty well on
its own and I'm gonna go ahead and take
this plastic bag and just set it to the
side we could reuse this again if we
wanted to at this point we can probably
start adding smaller pieces of tinder
mm-hmm you'll get a few of these little
pieces here we're gonna build that into
small we want it to be extremely light
airy sure to still allow the oxygen to
get in there exactly because if you take
away the oxygen you smother the fire
cool I think right there we're just
gonna let it sit for a couple minutes
now well that's going we can start
chopping up some of these pieces we just
down lying on the ground they're dry
it's almost like straw we're gonna pull
them into very thin fibers we want to
make something that resembles a bird's
nest something that's light airy and can
catch fire very quickly and now we need
to transfer this without disturbing the
coals as much as possible the way that I
like to do that is take this base mm-hmm
we're gonna take this grass we're gonna
put over top and we're just gonna gently
roll it over like this oh wow now you
can see all those hot coals transfer
down into the grass and we're just gonna
cover it over to help conceal block it
from some of the wind like this and now
because of all that straw the air can
flow through it and help build the heat
one trick that I use that it looks a
little bit funny I just stick this in my
hand and spin in circles hmm and it
really works honestly that's impressive
you can already see it smoking a little
bit more we're gonna give that a second
just for the heat to build back up yeah
but you can totally see there's a lot
more fuel catching on fire now what we
want to be seeing is thicker smoke and
we want to see it progressing we see the
smoke dying down or getting weaker like
slow down get out of the breeze give it
a chance for the heat to build this is
ready if you looked down in there you
can almost see glowing red embers now it
wants to light it wants to light it just
needs a little bit of a flick it's gonna
build up a little more a little spinning
trick oh you see that girl is hot flame
that's amazing boom and then we're out
here oh shoot sorry Derek is okay we've
clearly demonstrated forming fire well
that my friend is how to start a fire
with the sandwich bag and bright sunny
day it's nicely done I want to say a
huge thank you to grant here king of
random you should go check out his
channel there's lots of very random
things and it's taught me a thing or two
that's for sure
a lot about survival hacks and a lot of
those things that you really shouldn't
try at home and then we show you why you
shouldn't try them at home in fact we
just put a video on my channel trying to
melt glass we took a dr. pepper bottle
and melted that in the backyard and I
worked amazingly well so go check it out
I'll put a link in the description